Hello again, this is Dr. Kevin Connors and we're interviewing Dr. Brady Weirick.
Brady, tell us a little bit about your practice where you're located and what kind of practice
you specialize in.
Awesome.
My practice is the Intermountain Regenerative Medicine.
We are in Idaho Falls, Idaho, which is the southeast corner of Idaho.
We're about three hours north of Salt Lake City.
Our practice specializes in Regenerative Medicine and stem cell therapy where we do injections
for folks that have osteoarthritic joints and other inflammatory conditions that we
help them get and maintain control of those of the conditions and help them avoid joint
replacement surgery.
Okay.
Great.
Well, that's very rewarding and sure.
Absolutely.
Yes.
You know, we've talked before.
You said that, you know, some of the other issues that you deal with is that you want to
try to help a person holistically, they come in an e-paid or something like that, but
the more that you can do from a nutritional standpoint and environmental standpoint, the better
results you're going to have.
So today, I want to ask you some questions about electromagnetic frequencies that are harmful
to us like cell phones, cell phones, towers, tell me what do you give me a brief overview
of what those are and why we should be careful of those.
So electromagnetic field is a fancy way of saying radiation.
Electrons given off by a source from things that, well, I'm not going to say they shouldn't
be giving off, giving off these electrons, but they do.
And they're rated in sequence of how powerful of radiation they emit.
For example, it is common knowledge that an X-ray machine emits radiation, and that radiation
can actually cause cells to alter their DNA, damaging the cells and going into tumourous
problems.
So people are intimately familiar with going to the dentist, getting X-rays, and when they're
at the dentist, they put that big lead apron on to take uterus.
So that is on the far end of this electromagnetic radiation spectrum.
Well, there are a lot of things that are in our lives that are generally accepted as safe
even though they do still emit radiation frequencies.
For example, we all carry one in our pocket.
We all have one.
Electronic devices, laptop computers, cell phone towers, 5G networks, cell phone networks.
I'm looking out into the field here to the west of my office, and I can see those big green
electrical boxes.
They're going to be submitting some sort of EMF.
The more electronics that we jam into our cars, the more EMFs are going to be present.
And if these aren't harmonized EMFs, they're actually very harmful because we give ourselves
a low dose of these things on a daily basis, and people just aren't aware of what's going
on and what they're, what they're subjecting their cells to.
So this all, you know, I've known about these for a long time, I've been a big believer in
putting devices on our phones and on our laptops and that will help in harmonize some of
those electromagnetic frequencies.
But it didn't really domine until it was actually pretty recently that I came across a study
talking about the effects of electromagnetic fields and stem cell therapy, because I was
looking for information on how can I help get my patients the best, absolute best results.
And I came across a paper that was titled The Effects of EMF and stem cells.
And it went into really good detail about what the harm and the good that they can cause.
So when it comes to EMFs, there's either harmful EMFs or there's beneficial EMFs, the beneficial
EMFs are going to come from things like post-electromagnetic field therapy, beamer machines, et cetera.
They're going to emit a positive EMF that can actually help your own stem cells to proliferate.
And there are other things such as your cellphone, your microwave oven, all these other electronic
devices in our lives, they can emit a harmful EMF, which basically can lead to cell damage
and cancer.
I saw an interesting data recently that said of all the research papers that are out there
because that's the argument whether some people say, well, these aren't harmful, that's
a bunch of conspiracy theory.
But there's hundreds and hundreds of research papers out there.
And the interesting thing that I just read was 72 or 73% of the independent research that
was done showed that 73% of those showed that that cellphone radiation was harmful to the
body.
And only like 32% of the sponsored, it was sponsored by Verizon or a tier or something like
that.
So they just didn't publish the studies that showed negative effects.
And that's what you see of pharmaceutical companies too.
They'll send out their drug to be studied by 32 universities.
Well, if 23 of them say, come back and say, well, it didn't work, they just won't publish
those studies.
And then that's how they protect themselves.
And then they publish the studies that maybe the three universities that came back with very
positive results.
And those are the ones that they said to the FDA for verification and approval.
And that's what you were seeing as the pseudoscience.
It's a real science, but the problem is, is that when anything doesn't fit what they're
judging is that it just won't get published and it won't get submitted.
Right.
Get swept under the rug.
It's swept under the rug.
So the particular article that I'm referring to, Kevin, is actually, it's on my website.
If you go to iamregion.com, backslash resources.
The very top article that's there is the one that I've been referencing.
It was a, I think we could consider this one to be an independent study where they looked
at previous papers that had been written and came up with the conclusions based on those
particular papers, but what really stuck out to me is at the very bottom, and I put a note
in here, it says at the very bottom of page 11 or page 10 says, as a side comment, the number
of cancer patients in our society is growing alarmingly.
According to the environmental health specialist, besides chemical pollution, this condition may
be triggered by EMF exposure.
The further studies are therefore required to explore the phenomena both in vitro and in vivo.
We believe the EMF based therapeutic applications may be using the future for regenerative medicine
approaches as well as in the fight against cancer.
So these particular authors are very much in favor of using EMF as a regenerative therapy
modality.
That's clarified what that is, so when you talk about using positive EMFs, you're talking
about using pulse electromagnetic field therapy, you're talking about using rife therapy,
and those are the positive EMFs that are synced with your body's frequency in order to
help regenerate your body versus these damaging EMFs that are coming from cell phone towers
or dirty electricity and power lines and your cell phone use that are damaging and influencing
yourself.
Most people don't realize that we all are simply energy that is vibrating in a specific
frequency.
So, we could disrupt that with these aberrant energy sources that affect us negatively.
Absolutely.
You know, the way I explain it to patients all the time is if you look at us, our entire body
is made up of systems, and those systems are made up of different organs that the organs
are made up of different tissue.
The tissue is made up of different cells.
The cells are made up of different atoms, and one of the atoms is made out of, they're made
out of energy.
Period.
Now, if you take the therapeutic forms of energy and let's use, we're going to use rife
and we're going to use EMF for our example, if you apply those, then you can recharge the
state of the cell and help them to grow, help them to proliferate, or if you use the
wrong kind of energy or if you're surrounded by this dirty EMF from cell phones, circuit
breakers, et cetera, that can actually be detrimental to the cell's DNA leading to cancerous
legions.
Yeah.
Very scary, isn't it?
It is.
Like, I'm looking at this article again that I've referenced, and at the bottom of page
2, there's a great schematic that talks about the biochemical, the biophysical stimuli
that is applied to a stem cell.
Now, I think it's important here that we say that a stem cell is your body's own repetitive
mechanism.
You and I both have, we all have stem cells that your body holds in reserve to help you to
regenerate throughout your life.
But when we expose those stem cells to different stimuli, if they're good, they're going to go
down the green smiley face pathway, which leads to wound healing regeneration, desired
differentiation, desired growth, and homeostasis, or if we look at the abnormal or aberrant EMF
stimuli, they can go down the red frowny face pathway that leads to carcinogenesis, which
is cancer, pathological growth, undesired differentiation, teratoma formation and
degeneration.
Yeah.
That's where you talk scary.
And we're going to put a link to that article I'm looking at, and I pulled it up as you
gave me that your website address there, it's right on your website, it's IAMREGEM.com
and then you go to the resources under stem cells, and you'll see that article, it's your
first article, at least the first one you have listed there.
Boy, so you talk about trying to heal somebody's knee, and you're using stem cells to heal
their knee, and then they're, you know, hyper exposed to EMFs via whatever constant cell phone
use or dirty electricity in their house, or a bank of smart meters right below them in their
apartment building, it's going to affect their healing ability in the benefit of those
stem cells turning into the type of cells that are going to actually heal that meniscus.
Right.
Boy, it's it's scary, I mean, what are some things people could do?
I mean, you can't move to, you know, a place that doesn't, it doesn't have a cell phone
service.
We are, we are kind of tied to our cell phones over the last 10 years, all of us have basically
buried our cell phones, how, how can you still live in this world and function and give
some level of protection?
So the cheap easy freeways are to spend some time away from your devices.
For me personally, my cell phone cut off time is 9 pm, where my cell phone goes into
a different room than the one that I sleep in, and I will not look at my cell phone until
I'll after my well into my morning routine.
Well, that could be good for us emotionally as well, right?
Absolutely.
So it gives me a break.
The other thing is time outside, grounding is a big deal, you know, where you go the active
actually going out and putting your feet on the dirt, not with shoes, but actually grounding
yourself to the, to the earth is very, very beneficial, you know, the example I think of
is on occasion, find myself in Santa Monica, I love the beach there, and I love putting,
you know, my feet in the sand, just because you're helping to, you actually ground yourself
to the earth's resonance frequency, and if you want to go down another wormhole, look
up Schumann's wave, there's more fascinating stuff there, but you can ground yourself that
way.
There are commercially available products to help harmonize the EMFs coming off your
phone.
There's commercially available products that can, they can neutralize EMFs in an entire
building, even if it's, there's a lot of things you can do, you know, using rife as a therapeutic
activity tool, something using PEMF as a therapeutic, there's possibilities are endless.
Yeah.
I'll give you a specific example, and I wish I would have brought it in here with me, but
one of the products that we carry is called the home, the whole home harmonizer.
I had a woman visit with me about her seizure, because every time her son would rev up an
electronic device, in this particular case, it was a remote control car.
The EMF admitted from that, from that car would send her into a seizure.
Oh, goodness.
So we took this whole home harmonizer, and I did a little experiment that I brought it in,
and she, when she would walk into the, into our office, she could feel the EMFs in our
office.
It was, you know, you've seen cases like this before, the medical community just blows
these people off.
It's crazy, but you know, it's a real thing.
So I brought in one of the harmonizers, and I just set it by the front desk.
I didn't tell her.
And at the end of her visit that day, I just asked her, I said, do you feel something, you know,
what's different?
And she goes, something's calmer in here.
Anyway, a long story short, she took that harmonizer, put it in her purse, and she carries it
in her purse everywhere she goes, because it helps block some of the EMF frequencies for
her to have more of a normal life.
Right.
So there are products that are available that are very, very good at helping protect you from
those EMFs.
Right.
That product, we use that same thing that's heat-run for it.
And there's, they make a pendant, which is smaller than the home home harmonizer.
So people that are more sensitive to EMFs, I know there's a gene, there's four genes.
If you have defects on those genes, you're going to be more sensitive.
If you have chronic Lyme disease or something like that, you're going to be more sensitive.
If you have a chronic illness at cancer, you're going to be more sensitive.
So you need to take even greater precautions, but to prevent those diseases, you want to
take greater precautions.
So there's the things that you can do, put things on your cell phone, keep yourself
on a way, turn your Wi-Fi off at night, maybe try living without a Wi-Fi, just use plug-in,
you know, you know, internet, that can help.
So but it is, there's a lot of real danger just because you, you know, you don't necessarily,
you know, feel it, it could cause disease and cause, you know, health and cause of decrease
in healing ability and increase rate of aging and especially talk about dementia, the rate
of dementia increase and Alzheimer's increases going through the roof, and that's certainly
a piece of it as well.
So the more you could do to prevent that, the better.
Any closing thoughts on EMFs and anything else you do with your patients?
You know, it's, I think you hit it on the head when it's something people say it's something
that they absolutely ignore because it is a very, for 99% of people, it's a very, you can't
feel it, you can't sense it.
Even when you put these devices on yourself or on your phone, you still don't see a big
difference.
Or so people, it's hard for them to accept that something's actually helping them.
Right.
Exactly.
Well, thanks so much, Dr. Brady.
I'm going to share your website so we make sure that people get to that I am R E G E N dot
com.
You'll find a load of information.
You have a lot of great patient information there.
And the article you're referring to is how electromagnetic fields can influence adult stem
cells, positive and negative impacts, of course, talking about the positive impacts with things
like RIF and PMF and the negative impacts, things like cell phones.
We'll have you out again.
Appreciate it.
Thank you.
All right.
Bye-bye.